can we go back to just what steps you
took either to meet
howard barrish the producer or how did
you
what was your like initial pitch to him
yeah howard
bearish was an interesting um
milestone for me because prior to
meeting howard
i had developed scripts and written
scripts
but i was always in the minds remember
i'm learning about filmmaking
but in i'm in the mindset i'm gonna get
into an independent
i'm trying to raise independent
financing right and for me that looks
like my mother may be giving ten
thousand dollars if my mother had it or
a friend giving
five thousand dollars just finding money
like that or and i was led down the
wrong path
so many times talking to people in
atlanta talking to a casting director
who knew somebody with money in atlanta
and they get excited about the project
and say oh they yeah they we want to get
we want to get this thing going we like
it blah blah blah and you don't hear
from them again
right and that had happened so many
times like i mean
the meet them the amount of people i had
talked to that weren't really
i'm gonna say i'm gonna use a qualifier
here they never produced a film before
they never
uh given money to a film before so that
becomes
for any filmmaker going out there to
making a movie i mean certainly you can
work with people that have never done it
before and they're going to give money
but i think i just get it's just a
better
fit if somebody's done it before like
you take your film
or script to a production company that
makes it you know or you take it to
another
company that makes movies like you know
they have a history of that right
versus um okay let me you know
uh take it to this person let's take it
to this person i had done that for years
i don't know why but i was doing that
for years and so and i was always
reaching dead ends
okay and this is before um gofundme and
um and and all that but uh
so i had uh i was had worked on the
script
and i met with a camera guy friend of
mine
and he had worked with howard he'd work
with him on a few projects so he knew
howard
right and the camera guy said uh he said
yeah you know i think i can get it to
this guy
um howard bearish you know he makes
movies and uh yeah because he you know
he did some stuff with ava uh
duva doof i mean the guy didn't even
know who duvernay was right he's like
uh it's a friend of mine right he's like
uh yeah he did some stuff with ava
ava duva i said duvernay he said yeah
yeah that's her
that's her i said really so i got
excited immediately because i was like
oh howard bear she said stuff for david
doing
and i had already studied up on ava
right i knew who ava was and eve at that
time i think she did
did she sell what was she doing selma
yeah she was shooting selma
and uh yeah she's in the middle of
shooting some more shot selma
and so i was like yeah yeah yeah if you
can make the introduction please
and so he made the introduction and
howard called me
and uh we had well no i sent howard the
script first
and then it took howard a while to read
it but you learn that in this business
too people are like
like people are not pressed to read your
script you're not going to give it to
them they're like oh yeah i want to read
over the weekend
it just doesn't happen and so you learn
to i mean i'm even more detached now but
back then i was still like
has he read it yet has he read it yet
but i know i'm patiently like okay don't
call him in a week don't call him in two
weeks
but then i think i called him like maybe
three weeks later and he said oh no i
haven't read it yet but i'm gonna get to
it i'm gonna get to it
and then uh the next call he called me
and he said i read your script and i
didn't know howard from adam right
that was a really nice guy like he's
really cool he's really like
unassuming you wouldn't know that he has
a bathroom award
or that he's been nominated for an emmy
you know
that he uh produces these big cw
campaign
commercials i mean you just wouldn't
know it and so that's what i liked about
him
like he's really like just low-key and
assuming
unassuming and so he just had an
off-the-cuff chat yeah like your script
he said you know
it's okay he says you know once you come
in we can talk
and uh he invited me down to the office
and i came down to the office and i met
with him
and we just i think we kind of just hit
it off right away
again he's just a very unassuming
low-key kind of guy
and uh you know he talked about ava
you know the journey of making
independent films and why he was
passionate about
supporting younger artists new emerging
filmmakers
anyhow he'd uh he was just committed to
that i mean he's just you know he was
committed today did it with ava and
so he uh took the film
you know took the script and then we
started to work together at that point
in terms of developing like i said it
took over a year
to get it to where we needed it to be
and during that point i would just
rewrite it i would give it to him and he
would give me notes and
rewrite it and give it to him give me
notes and so we went back and forth for
you know a few drafts until we got it to
where we
needed it to be and you emailed him
initially
do you is that right yeah i emailed him
uh
or did i call him i think i called him i
think i called i don't know
you know sometimes i write the emails
but it's like it depends
because i don't want to catch people off
guard you know when you write when you
call them right away it's like oh
hello you know they have to adjust
themselves and i don't want them to
play pretend and all that stuff so um
but i think in howard's case because
brian the guy
i met set up the introduction
um i think i called him
i think i called him or maybe emailed
him i don't know
i don't know it could have been an email
actually and he gave me his number and
he said let's talk
it may have been an email it could have
been because i like that soft intro
sometimes it gives people
they can gather themselves on the other
end you know well he doesn't know if
you're a solar panel
salesman yeah he didn't know you know of
course i hadn't
and you know how it took a big gamble
too because to see
in my mind i'm thinking i'm ready i can
do a film i know i can right
but from the other person who's
financing the film
who's going to produce it he didn't know
because
it's not like i'd done a i did yeah i
did some shorts and he saw the shorts
but it's not like i had done a feature
before
features a whole nother animal we can
talk about that it's like
um a short film is a short film to
itself but
a feature in terms of shooting it
we did hours and 17 days the actors
following first act drama second act
third act
and then arc of characters and then um
uh
just the stamina as a director to show
up
every day with with a game plan it takes
something
you know and everybody everybody and
sometimes you can fail on the job
like you know what i mean like you can
be a first-time director and get all set
but
you better have first ad who's very
clear about
laying out a schedule uh a dp who's done
this numerous times so they've got you
sort of
um they're supporting you in making that
first feature and so
the margin of error for you becomes less
right does that make sense because
you're a first-time director but yet
you've got
you know an ad an experienced producer
in howard
and you got a dp who can sort of steer
the ship but when you
when you don't have that you know and
then you got a first-time director out
there
anything can happen so you you don't
know
you know you become an unproven talent
until you've done it
you know and uh so i knew i could do it
i felt i was very confident about that
i've been on enough sets
and my experience doing the shorts and
the documentary and i had
i had an acumen around film i studied a
lot of films i had uh
yeah but i mean the things surprised me
on the set too i mean it was like
yeah it was it was still it was still a
challenging experience you know like i
was still figuring things out
you know what i mean like i remember one
day i showed up on set and kiera kelly
was our dp cara kelly now shoots uh
queen sugar uh black woman dp
really talented and so i remember one
morning we did
a shot list top to bottom right and so
we knew
exactly how we were going to approach
each scene
the movie in itself you can kind of do
that with a 16-day shoot and you or you
better do that
you better be very specific about what
you're going to cover because you don't
have a lot of
like we're not we don't have a spielberg
set where we can play with
or we're going to shoot this one scene
one day you know or david fincher yeah
let's just do this one scene
one day you know like we gotta shoot
like really four or five scenes in a day
and so um but i showed up one morning
and i said i got an idea for the shot
right and she looked at me she said yeah
i said yeah why don't we start here
and put it on a dolly and then move it
up here as they get out of the car right
he said wow that's really cool i like
that she said but that's not on the show
list we didn't talk about that
i said i know i know but it's cool
because i got inspired right i got
inspired that night before i said i know
it's a cool shot it's gonna look really
cool and uh she said yeah no but we
didn't talk about it and i said
but she said but you want to do it i
said yeah she said but it's going to
take a little time
because we got to put the dolly blah
blah blah blah i said nah but
let's go let's go for it and they
started to set up the track right
and one dolly man and
what and he was one dollar grip and he
was laying the track
and he was you know leveling the track
and then i hadn't even put the dolly up
there yet and i looked at him i said
damn this is 10 minutes
and he hadn't even laid that track yet
and he's still trying to level it
and i'm like 15 minutes and i said scrap
it
let's go back to the plan let's go back
she said you sure she's a really
professional dp and what i liked about
it was she's going to give me my vision
right so she was cooperative in that
sense you know a lot of dp's
you know argumentative and whatnot i
mean not all of them but you know i've
heard stories
but she was very like it's your vision
let's do it
um but i saw how long it was taking to
put that track up
and i said kill it kill it let's go back
and she said you sure i said yeah
so that was an instance where in terms
of me growing as a director knowing
especially with this budget
what you can do and what you can't do
right and we could not afford
whether time money or otherwise to lay a
track down
and do a dolly and i didn't have a
trained crew like that
you know like i didn't have i've been on
other sets where
uh they have dolly grips
and two or three people working to dial
it we didn't have that
you know we had like two people in the
dollar in the grip department two people
in the lighting department
some days we spread out to three but on
bigger scenes
but we didn't have that so i was like
you know what so i learned my lesson i
may have cost this 15 minutes
but if i had continued on that path to
do that shot i would probably cost us
about
45 minutes really because then now you
have to allow
for the shot one time you have to allow
for the dolly oh they missed the dolly
mark
then you got to allow for the pull focus
oops he missed his mark so everybody got
allowed for a mistake right and then the
guy pushing it
oh he made a mistake so it's like you
know
it it increases the um uh the take value
or the ratios in terms of shooting it
too so
i surrendered it but i say that by way
of a learning lesson
you know i learned by doing the first
feature too
and imagine if she had fought you on it
you might have spent a half hour
trying to prove your point oh yeah so it
was brilliant that she said okay
sure okay let's and then you got to see
within 15 minutes
it was gonna cost more time yeah exactly
exactly so you know
sometimes it's just there's no getting
around doing a first feature
like you have to do it and like people
think it's
i don't know if people think they can
dial it in or it's easy
i don't sometimes i get that impression
when i talk to filmmakers especially
that
somebody that haven't done it before
they think they can just they're going
to be great at it but
you know it's like anything else you
know whether you do sound
or you deep they don't look at it like a
dp like a dp you know
when you shoot something it's going to
take a minute to perfect your craft
it's just going to take a minute
lighting you know
camera lenses it's a very technical
thing but being a good director can be
that too
right sometimes people think you just
step on set and just oh boom let's make
it happen
but no you know the good directors the
really good ones they worked at it they
worked at it
so um i have an appreciation for
directing and
i do a lot of studying on it blocking
you know
coverage you know working with actors
i've taken classes
you know in terms of directing classes
brad barnes does a great
uh director's working with actors class
i've taken that frederick douglass
uh writing um because i think all
directors should be able to write i mean
it helps
it helps you to understand story arc
where it's going
you don't become it's just you know yeah
it just helps
you become a better story technician
so you know i
i believe in the craft i believe in
knowing the craft i've worked with
actors a lot
and so then it becomes very helpful yeah
having done many short films when you
actually started with the feature
did you think you were going to be as
calm
under pressure when things you're having
to come up with not just a plan b
but a plan c and then you know that
there's all this money
riding on it there's all this time
you've got to make your day yeah did you
realize how much pressure that would be
having to make these decisions on the
fly
yeah it was gradual it was gradual
because um
i heard somebody explain it to me like
this like you could be a producer
right and say somebody's driving you
there's a driver and he drives you to no
no
this is a better example okay so you're
going to school right
and so your mother's driving you every
day she's driving every day to school
you're just kind of sitting there you're
on your phone you're talking or you're
on the email
and you've done this route to school
like a million times right
and then one morning your mother says
okay you drive and all of a sudden
you're like uh
which way am i going right so it can be
like that a little bit
you know like i had i've been even
though i'd been on a million sets
and i had worked as a sound technician
and um
you know i've added it's not you know
but to be in the seat of dr
directing it's a whole different
conversation the decisions that are
being put on you the questions i mean
you get a million questions a day right
and then having to just be very clear
about your shot
and then being able to walk away from a
scene saying we got it or we don't got
it
we need to stay longer right or how
okay i shot this i took more time than i
needed to i really don't screw myself up
at the end of the day
so now i have to think about a wonder
and wow i can get make my day that way
so i mean it was it was it was very it
was challenging
i mean it was it was challenging at
times you know i was getting that muscle
up
you know to become yeah i was getting
that muscle i think i think
i came with a lot of strong stuff like i
work with actors
a lot and so that was sort of easy for
me
you know um technically working with the
equipment
was it was i had a handle on that i
think it was the scheduling
and kind of knowing how long things
would take like the action sequences i
did like i did not know it was going to
take as long as it took
and so when we did the schedule and so
i'm sitting there as the ads doing the
schedule
and he's saying yeah this is this is and
i'm signing off on it
you know and i'm signing off on the
basic basic i don't really have the exp
i mean i'm not i haven't done the action
right but i'm signing off on it
basically yeah it should take that long
it should take that long there's a
difference between that and having
experience doing it
right that's why you're going to do your
second feature your third feature you're
like no no no i need more time
no no that's not going to work oh yeah i
can cut that yeah we can get that in the
early point and
we're done you know like we did a lot of
car shots the hostess trey i mean one
day the guy set up the hostess straight
and it wasn't my fault and it wasn't um
the ads fault but the guy just took
forever to do
to set up the hostess tray for the car
mount shot right
it's because he didn't know what he was
doing he just did not know what he was
doing and it took him a long time
or i shouldn't say he was green he was
an experienced guy so that's the other
thing when you work with
independent or lower budgeted films
sometimes you're not getting the cream
of the crop
right so you're getting guys that you
know trying to break in trying to you
know
you know elevate themselves in their own
careers but this is where they are right
now
so the guy just took forever and so i
was like wow this is killing this man
this is killing us
and so i at the minute i had to just
switch up and say we can't do this we
got to go to another shot
or he screwed because he didn't know
what he was doing or he just screwed us
now we had to go from
i couldn't do the cross coverage i
wanted now i had to do one coverage
right
from one side of the car and so now and
i learned this when we're doing this
the actors the actors already known this
because they had played
um they had been on a lot of sets you
know you got to give credit to actors
man i mean
the really good ones they do this a lot
and they know what to do
so when they played the scene they
played to this camera so even though i'm
side angle
they played this way right and so
i covered the camera covered their
performance in a way where they knew the
blocking
right in the car now the minute i said
to them i think we have time to go to
the other side they were like whoa
oh we played for this camera you switch
if now if we know you were going that
way look
we could have played it like this she
could have turned but
we thought it was going to be one angle
you see i was like ah
got it got it so we just stuck with the
one shot
yeah i learned that you know what i mean
on the set that day
okay so actors you know they know you
know but i always like to inform my
actors anyway this is the blocking this
is the shot
blah blah blah but the minute i said
we're going to switch it and go another
way they were like
but we played it this way for this
camera it looks beautiful for that
camera
but if they had known we were going two
cameras guess what they'd be turning
like this
turning like that yeah so
yeah there's no there's no um there's no
getting around doing a first-time
feature
and i don't think and hey listen you can
do a lot of preparation
but until you're on that set until
you're there the first day
um i mean it still becomes a first time
feature experience
yeah just be as prepared as you can be
and surround yourself with good people
and we did that you know and howard
having done uh this
a number of times i mean sometimes i get
to sit in the morning i'm seeing howard
moving to jenny
i mean he's a hands-on producer too so
not as that and he used to be an a.d
so he was an a.d in canada for a lot of
years before he became a producer
so the last two days we lost our a.d
because he was sick
i mean he just got i think he had some
kind of food poisoning or whatever not
from the set but
you know he got sick and so howard had
stepped in
and guess what both days we
we managed to rap before schedule like
an hour early
both days and he was so efficient and on
time
and it was just like i was like howard
how did that he say hey man
but he knows how to a.d you know he
knows how to run a set
so i was blessed to have him as a
producer on my first
[Music]
film
you